yeah I see
in
um
[Music]
that information
you know
[Music]
many times
[Laughter]
movies
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
Indonesia
I am
alone
[Music]
from me
assalamualaikum welcome back to the
realest podcast in the Dunya three
Muslims we're joined here with home base
minus brother Romi keep him in indoors
you're muted Habibi
you're still muted bro
every time you click on mute it just
goes to mute
maybe you gotta hold the mute thing the
entire time bro
I'm just playing
why is my camera look so close
I don't know
I wasn't like this in the backstage
what'd you do yeah that's that's
definitely weird bro
mellow protect us from the charity
the two Muslims
awareness of day asks what are we
recording or revealing address social
insurance number where
man's dipping that's it
our brothers on hosts love the chat it
is just going to be me today we're gonna
do a solo stream
all right Arnold's just gone bro he's
out of t3m
subhanallah look what you've done bro
I'm gonna put this right up this is what
you get for spelling his name like that
God he asks what is the name of the
recited that's brother yahir busier
close friend of ours
from Ireland
Miller Blossom subscribe to his channel
watches vlogs
favorite channel to Muslims let's see if
one has back now
there we are
home
Depot
it's not just over here it's not exactly
straight but
I don't really wanna
gotta be professional with it
let me let me put this up here
to solo uh bro so Chad can you hear me
comment if you can hear
fired
right now
I need to make sure of this before we go
right in
there we go
alhamdulillah
bro almost like block from stream
that would not have been good
okay so we got a huge announcement today
first of all before we even jump right
into this stream we are going to be
doing let me put on this side we're
going to be doing
what was that changing back
one more time
uh bro nothing we play too much also do
you notice that you're a little bit
squished yeah why is this what are you
doing bro
you got me bro
listen so oh a huge announcement first
of all brothers and sisters jazak love
her for making this on the stream bear
with our Technical and maturity
difficulties we have brother Dylan
Madden on the stream this Sunday
June
18th I believe and he will be talking
about Islam
exclusive things about Andrew Tate the
pbd podcast behind the scenes stuff he's
a close friend of Jewel the sartorial
shooter and Andrew Tate with Tristan
Tate we met him we ate with him we took
him to the Masjid we exchanged some
thoughts and Views and after we left
alhamdulillah y'all probably noticed
that he's been talking a lot about Islam
and religion
he is known as a businessman
in the freelancing and
wealth sphere
so inshallah make sure you guys tune in
for that
something wrong
yeah alhamdulillah but there's something
wrong because it's making me starting to
look like Slenderman over here
not like the uh Discord but I mean they
know bro they know so
bro Discord was unacceptable man how was
it this go Discord has you like
stretched the hell up bro beyond all
repair
like after that point bro it's not good
for anyone that's fine
Mr squished
may Allah protect on her from my
spelling and the squishing I mean I mean
I mean bro
all right so guys first question we'll
get right into it we're gonna maximize
this time so me and I don't can go pray
Isha in about an hour or so
Ricardo asked Are You Gonna collab with
dawa over Dunya inshallah that is
definitely something that we are looking
forward to inshallah
guys comment down below any of your
questions make sure that they are very
appropriate
so I know what do you think of this
you're muted again bro
you're still muted bro
Dylan Madden is a freelancing Prof in
the War Room yes bro alhamdulillah
honor the real world not the War Room
they changed it
they always know if the superpowers
what are your thoughts on Quran only
Muslims I think that Bradley bro when it
comes to quota and only Muslims or
quranists also known as Hadith rejecters
these are men and women that
fundamentally do not read and comprehend
and understand the Quran correctly
because if you read the Quran it says
never will you be or it says oh Prophet
never will they be successful unless
they take you as the decider the
arbitrator so this clearly shows that
Prophet Muhammad peace universe and be
upon him was set here as the perfect
example and the best of creation as a
role model for all of mankind men and
women so it only makes sense that we
have to use and follow his teachings
furthermore nothing ever
did any uh Prophet or messenger do out
of their own free will or own accord
that was in contravention to what Allah
has legislated or ordered so anything
that Prophet Isa Prophet Musa Prophet
Ibrahim uh Muhammad all of these
prophets they have only done what Allah
has legislated they've never done
anything in contravention to that so
understanding that Hadith doesn't
necessarily mean that there's just a
bunch of more rules and a bunch of more
restrictions and my life is going to be
this much more miserable stuck for Allah
it's nothing like that it just simply
means that now we have a more complete
and more expanded instruction manual so
we have things to tell us how to eat how
to use the washroom how to you know
clean ourselves how to do good business
how to greet other people how to treat
our wives how to treat people in society
how to give charity and the virtues that
are more in-depth than the Quran itself
on Homebrew I really hope you're not
Frozen right now
oh no there we go
nah bro
there's no way
Brothers do you see this right now yeah
I'm definitely not frozen bro I don't
know what's happening though damn things
around with the camera yeah bro if I
were you I would just like did you can
you use it in a sentence bro
who
you know I would plug it out and put it
back in
manual that Freeze Frame looked crazy
fight or even Ollie
I am Muslim alhamdulillah
so simply a slave writes okay Angel says
device not connected Brothers I will
bring him on as soon as I can inshallah
some as he's back is there any way you
can get brother Muhammad from Muslim
land to join you guys and speak with
sneako next time or speak with any other
influencer insha Allah we have already
had him on the stream and he spoke to
three influencers you got myself you are
on her and you got around me so they've
been there done that bro but inshallah
we can consider this Nico one may Allah
bless you for the recommendation
Mahmoud writes assalamu alaikum Brothers
hope you are all doing well
alhamdulillah we are can't complain a
while ago I heard brother Ibrahim X or
formerly known as Lord bear before y'all
get tight it's not Lord
but it's a landlord all right he owns
land in Scotland he's working on a
project similar to me can you get us in
contact to collab
so yes bro the best thing you can do is
go on his channel comment on some of his
streams or join hisagram inshallah
there we go money right there look at
that
I look normal
alhamdulillah
how did you do it what is your secret
sauce
I can't tell you though all right bro
Ali NASA asked what cities are you guys
based in
Mecca and Medina
I'm just playing Yusuf have you guys
watched the series Allah and the cosmos
I watched a little bit of it my parents
watched it and sent it to me
how about you all know
bro you're still muted
you still muted bro I'm gonna need you
to say well you're not messing around
bro because this is getting
unprofessional
no
okay
inshallah
let's start with this do you think this
is coming true the gel will not come and
so the people neglect his mention and
until the imams abandoned his mention
um what do you think
put the thing back up I was doing it
in the comment
got you bro
I don't know
I don't know about people wrong because
I mean whenever we're together bro we
talk a lot about that stuff
yeah that I mean from what I understand
is he's been making it very
normal
you know like the symbology everywhere
Cinema that symbology what am I saying
symbolism
the symbolism like the eye the one eye
every single place that you go
so I don't know I don't think it's him
not being talked about I think it's
once it's so normalized that
if you would have mentioned it you put
in even say anything because to you is
normal
but then again
foreign
let me finish what I'm saying bro
when it comes to the Hadith mentioning
that if you abandon Salah you're
basically a cafe like the difference
between a Believer and a disbeliever is
abandoning so I believe that's what it
says word for word the scholars have
this is what I'm going to say and then
on who's going to say what he says the
scholars that I know they've all said
the abandoning Salah doesn't necessarily
mean that you're struggling with Salah
you're praying sometimes you're not
praying sometimes this is more so for
people that literally in their belief
they believe the Salah itself is not
something that is necessary or mandatory
or father as a Muslim so they'll say you
know what salah's actually a joke we
don't actually have to do this I don't
know who said to do this why are we
praying it's referring to that other
Scholars have consulted said that it is
you know just not praying at all it's
been a long time you don't even want to
pray so that's kind of the difference if
you just miss a prayer it doesn't take
you out of the fold of Islam it is
obligatory it is a major sin if you miss
Salah that's my two cents
I don't know
damn what do you have to say counselor
no I'm not I'm not going to say anything
because
there was a arrogant of me to say
let me give a fatwa
may Allah bless you for your higher
you see him
today bro it does have a point
that's two for two for the name spelling
can you imagine bro after today it's on
hill
and so the UK Brothers call you anyway
demand them
yuriken asks what happens when you feel
like Allah isn't giving you what you
want and it doesn't seem like he's
paying attention to you why is that oof
on her going bro
you're being tested
to see how patient you're gonna be
because when we don't get what we want
right away
we tend to get pretty
overwhelmed maybe angry maybe sad
maybe we start to play the victim card
like why me why me
not saying that's you I'm just saying
some people this is how we act right
and
when we get into the situations like
let's say we're angry because
something's happening
I've heard this from Sheikh Hamza
Hamza Yusuf
yeah he said if you're angry
what are you really angry at if Allah is
the one that's doing everything and if
Allah's
is perfect and he does everything
perfectly and everything's happening for
a reason and we don't know
if he's doing everything perfectly and
something's not happening how you wanted
to
if you're angry like who are you really
angry at
so let's just put into perspective that
when you're not getting something right
away you just have to be patient because
Allah doesn't do things to work against
you he does things for you but you it's
up to you or it's up to us to handle
those situations appropriately
because otherwise we will not be
experiencing those situations
use of Rights revealed from Christianity
you guys spam a little bit in the chat
alhamdulillah we have a new brother
I'm gonna come back to this one because
this is a long one foreign what is the
best thing you will get to experience in
Jannah
um objectively I can't say but
subjectively what I would say is I'm
looking forward to how every man will
have two wives no man will remain
unmarried and the women there will not
experience any jealousy like the worldly
don't need jealousy I really want to see
that
what about you all know
the thing that I want to see the most
two things actually
three things three things three things
first thing
is
to see my spouse in the perfected form
and they see me in my perfect form
inshallah second thing
is tasting the foods
in Jannah
because we told her it's it's like
the dates the bananas that we've eaten
here in this life
but it's actually nothing like that he's
Allah is giving us this example so we
can have an idea of what it's like
and then number three is to see
Allah
um
brother ozone writes you all need to
change the name of the channel
uh any suggestions nah bro that suggests
you just mind your own business bro to
be honest
let's go
Amar what is your advice on combating
laziness and on motivation
just get it done bro
just get it done that's it
it's really good
to be honest
I realizes after months of
reflecting and contemplation and
pondering the the difference between
someone that just gets it done with
speed and someone that doesn't get it
done at all is not that the person that
gets done feels like it or doesn't feel
like they just get it done bro
and also talking too much and doing less
action
will make you probably most likely not
take the action
would you like a podcast with MH we've
already done one and inshallah we're
going to do another one in the weeks to
come let's go after that probably
in-person tool we'll see
this is true this is very true
if Hedonism is bad why is it a reward in
Jannah oof
because his entire life is a test so
first let me actually I should have
started this off by saying
at the end of the day Allah Knows Best
but if we can use our logic to try to
comprehend this
while we're here
okay it's a test some means everything
else in this life is a test
if we partake in hedonism
well then you're failing the test
because if you look at the guidebook the
guidelines for this life
it will tell you to not fall into your
desires to not follow your own desires
to not do Hedonism basically
your own
bro something inside of you is going to
tell you not to do this like let's say
you go off and start watching
pornography you start having sex with
every single woman you don't have
anything serious or anything like this
bro something inside of you is going to
be like something's wrong
so that's clearly why you don't do
Hedonism in this life now why is
Hedonism something
or the idea of it's something that's in
Jannah as well because
in Jannah everything is perfection
and
in this life we have a pleasure but the
pleasure
the more we do it we'll begin to
drop
in general we do something the pleasure
continues to go up
so this will owe you you know it's it's
kind of like the example of the kid
where the kid is told hey
if you wait for this marshmallow
if you wait x amount of time then you're
gonna get like five marshmallows or ten
marshmallows
but if you eat it now you're only gonna
have that marshmallow
it's the same thing
you can have Hedonism now and only have
the pleasures of this life which are
they only get worse the more you do them
or
you can wait and you can have the
pleasures in the next life which only
get better the more that you do them
I like that wrong
oh we got three for three bro calling
you on Hill
here's more than a few graphs
listen
we bug boys
always supporting us may Allah bless you
always showing love
everybody make the world one of our
biggest supporters
Hamza
is being a practicing Muslim first of
all
is being a practicing Muslim is the only
thing that can keep my mind at peace as
a man it's a shame I'm not as of now or
it's a shame I'm not as of now and I
know that's not right good at least you
know I've made decent money through work
but feel empty
all right
could you put that back up sir
yes brother I can
explain what you mean what kind of piece
are you looking for in your mind
yeah look out for your your channel bro
don't don't send another Super Chat
may Allah bless you I'll make sure to
look out for Hamza
but listen bro when it comes to peace of
mind
I genuinely feel like if you have Islam
if you have Allah you have nothing else
you have everything if you don't believe
me you will one day but if you have
everything in the Dunya that has to
offer you don't have Allah don't have
Islam you don't have a Deen you don't
have Iman
you got nothing bro
you're making all this money and you're
saying you're empty it's because it
isn't about the money we've been sold
this this false sense of success as a
masculine man from looking up to people
not gonna name any names now but fast
cars women money as like the gold
standard to like having it but I'm
telling you this right now
if you don't have this but you have the
sweetness of Iman and you wake up every
day with no mental health problems no
spiritual problems your heart is not
suffering bro that is priceless nothing
can buy that but if you have all the
money compared to maybe otherwise you
got women you have abundance of
everything you have nothing
yeah
and again please give a better
explanation of what you're looking for
in terms of peace of mind but provide
that it's it's exactly that you know you
don't do things for money in this life
you have to do things to have purpose
to benefit this world
to do the best that you can because
you have to understand that Allah put
every single one of us here for a reason
and if we were to all the follow our
purpose
imagine the change that I couldn't do in
this life
but please give your explanation of what
you're looking for in terms of the Peace
of Mind
thank you
you know some fools for real
he's gonna change his name on the gov
you know
does anyone ever call you in East
Pakistani as an insult uh yeah it's
usually just west pakistanis calling me
that
Ali trouble right so let's show them how
much we appreciate them they deserve
alhamdulillah bless you yes I've seen
imams doing it we're not gonna give a
photo but listen
just because you see a Muslim doing
something doesn't mean Islam will allow
it encourage it permit it and make it
obligatory or even acceptable by Allah's
standards but
similarly if you don't see Muslims doing
it it also doesn't mean that something
is not obligatory so understanding that
Muslims are unfortunately and this is
unfortunately
by the way Association Works Muslims are
going to be representative of Islam
right this is just the way it is just
like Christians are going to be
representative of Christianity Jews are
going to be representative of Judaism
it's the world we live in right however
it doesn't mean necessarily that if you
have some people that are slipping into
deviance or kofor or Haram that it makes
things acceptable whatsoever
I'm personally gonna say just as a
Layman when it comes to shisha stay away
from it when it comes to any of these
things even vaping stay away from it
because at the very least it's not
anything Islamic it's an Arab thing it's
a middle eastern thing I agree
still was burying your daughters once
upon a time does that mean now Islam
encourages it of course not
but you must understand that when it
comes to these things why are we doing
these things you look so cool having
that little pipe in your mouth and like
you're like you're a fire breathing
dragon bro like what is this
at the very least you are imitating
those that are deviant
and at the very most you could be doing
something that is Haram and most likely
probably is bro again not a scholar but
stay away from him there's no benefit in
that and there is harmful especially if
there's nicotine like tobacco you're
literally harming yourself
and if you Google it
studies will show that approximately an
hour of smoking shisha
is and by the way that's like rough
lower level equivalent a lot of men I
know
literally smoke for like hours but an
hour of smoking shisha is equivalent to
I forgot how many packs of cigarettes
bro just do your own research
took a lot of uh
humility to say that bro May Lord bless
you you come a long way
one will see a full podcast with all
three Muslims never
unless you make the world for us
that's
a very difficult thing my brother
the way that we really stop
okay the way that we really really start
it all starts
with you making the decision
that this is it
that you're no longer going to be a
slave to your desires
because at some point you have to wake
up and understand that
this whole thing you hear about shirk
and not associating partners with Allah
you do realize
when you start partaking in your desires
and your desires control you
that means you are a slave to your
desires
so and when we should perform That Shook
and when you can internalize that and
you don't want that to happen anymore
and you only want to have Allah be
basically the thing that you're
submitting to the one that you're
submitting to
it changes everything
but until you have that
that decision just 100 sit inside of you
that this is it
something's really going to change
because you gotta think about your
belief in Islam
if an atheist comes to you and then they
ask you
about oh like well what about this this
and this and they try to make you
believe in something other than Islam
they try to make you disbelieve in Islam
would you disbelief yes or no
if I would you disbelieve
I want you to ask me that one more time
bro
if an atheist came to you and try to
make you disbelieve in Islam would you
believe that would you follow exactly
what he's saying no no why
because you believe in Islam rationally
so you believe uh a hundred percent in
Islam 100 correct okay well then your
belief
in the fact that you will no longer go
back into your desires has to be the
same exact level as your belief in Islam
100 because there's a difference I was
told this by
a close brother he said there's a
difference between 99 percent
and 100 percent
um hello bless his brother I miss him
for the sake of Allah but when you do
something 99 versus you do 100 there's a
huge difference there's a difference
there's not much difference between 98
and 99 but between 99 and 100 there's
that level of I've completely taken this
leap of faith and doesn't have to be
blind faith but it's complete certainty
or yakin in that you're doing what
something no one else can force you to
do well no one else can brainwash you to
do you've generally made that jump
yourself
is on her okay with being called on hill
or should we stop what do you think
chief
believe that anyone's name
is exactly how you should pronounce it
so pronounce it
keep my brother's name out your mouth
just be respectful
it goes without saying boys
Leon has even if for whatever reason
it's not Haram it's a bad decision to
smoke yeah this is why you almost
understand in Islam there's difference
between things that are immoral and
illegal makru and Haram if something is
macro immoral it doesn't mean that
automatically it's you know it's you're
allowed to do it because I know a lot of
people have that type of mindset right
but when did it always become about
Haram like if something's not Haram okay
cool then we're good no like at the end
of the day you want to get to a point
where you don't play around with my crew
bro matter of fact a lot of majority of
you know traditional contemporary
Scholars not today obviously not none of
these ones selling their soul to the
west but I'm talking Once Upon a Time
like the early early Scholars of Islam
bro all of them took my crew as Haram
none of them looked at it as macro so
this is a very like modern thing where
people are like you know okay I can dip
my feet in the water as long as I don't
go in so I'm good it's like no bro it's
deeper than that
the thing I heard is that
if something is my crew
I could you know could lead you to
something that's Haram
why would you even play around with that
and I want to give you all this thing
that I want to add to unho's point that
it it is why would you play around with
that but it's also you almost understand
that playing around with something in
the early stages doesn't seem that bad
at all
so you know how Allah says in the Quran
do not go near Zina unlawful intercourse
or intimacy what does Allah say that
it's because anytime you have something
Haram right let's say it's doing a
substance let's say it's I don't know
just hooking up with some classmate and
you know outside of marriage just all
this hookup culture nonsense uh whether
it's stealing anything that's Haram
right the very first step genuinely
might be something that's not Haram and
generally models be something that
doesn't feel Haram or seem Haram
objectively speaking
so it's like the earlier steps or ones
for anything that leads to Haram right
the earliest steps are those things that
they generally seem okay they generally
seem harmless it's very ambiguous right
no one knows it's it doesn't even seem
hot on and then the deeper you go into
shaitan's footsteps following him the
more clearly they get hold on but
because each step is so gradual it feels
very normal
it's kind of like when we had uh the
story of the the Frog when you're
cooking a frog in like a pot of boiling
water and you're like slowly slowly
Notch by notch increasing the
temperature of the water boiling and
eventually the Frog gets cooked and
doesn't even realize it that it got
boiled so it's kind of the same thing
and it's only us that's gonna be the
loser bro at the end of the day no one
else
oh he's such an extremist
okay so I will tell you what I've heard
from different chefs
I've heard from some shares
that bring in the mosque every single
prayer
is obligatory
I've heard that for some
you know it's Margaret Isha
and
Fajr
and I've heard that no it is not
obligatory to pray every single prayer
in the Masjid
but
that it is a great loss if you don't
so which one of those do you want to
follow
that let you be the judge
simply put if something is Sunnah but
it's not father
you might as well do it just to be safe
if something's my crew but it ain't
Haram best to avoid it you get what I
mean so an example of this is the
qurbani right
there's a word for an Arabi but we're
just going to call it the Quran is
basically when you or you can't
Slaughter an animal right obviously it's
a quarterback and you eat the second eat
either other coming up you are you're
going to have to pay for you know the
slaughtering pay for the meat get the
animal and you know you spend money on
it and it will basically be distributed
and there's a there's an equation right
like one-third to the poor like those
that need it and then the other third
and then the other third so it's
something that's from the religion no
doubt it's not something that's better
or anything like that however you all
must understand that aside from the
hanafi school of thought the hanafi
mother which is one of the four dominant
Sunni schools of thought they believe
that giving the qurbani is obligatory
for anyone or I believe it's a man but
anyone that is able to so if you can
afford it you have to however all other
schools of thought the closest sahaba
you know Omar othman Abu Bakr
and as I mentioned the other three
schools of thought they say that it's
not obligatory
it's not it's Sunnah like as in if you
do it you'll be rewarded if you don't
there's no punishment
now does this mean I'm gonna be like wow
you know what bet I'm okay I'm Gonna
Save my little a little bit of a chump
change because it really is the chump
change if you understand how much one
CAD or one USD has
if you give it in South Dakota to your
afterlife bro you will not be holding on
to your money
as if you know you're trying to save for
this rainy day or anything like that
you'd be giving soulfully bro you were
giving heartfully you would not be
holding on to these things being stingy
so when it comes to corbani
ask yourself this it's Sunnah doesn't
mean okay just because it's not about
the term I'm not gonna do it no of
course not we're still gonna do it
because we should do it obviously if
you're in a typical financial situation
you're not a good one I'm not gonna tell
you you know you're forced to do it or
anything but just do it if you're able
to why not
so awesome
when it goes to the other question
something that I want to add is that if
you haven't played every single prayer
in the Masjid before
then I invite you to do so
just see what happens for yourself and
then you choose
hmm
Alisha was in Toronto from 5 a.m to 1pm
can hit you up on the river inshallah
bro just text me
how should I know if I follow Sunni or
Shia how you should know isn't what you
believe do a little bit of research
contact the proper scholar and I want
you to understand that Sunni Islam is
not necessarily a sect in
you know dividing itself aside from
other things because of difference or
anything like that that's what all other
steps are Sunni Islam was essentially
made a sect right even the word Sunni
it's not like it was there back then at
all but we have Sun Islam because
mentioned that there are going to be
different sects for example in one
Hadith inventions that those of my ummah
or sorry those of uh Judaism I believe
divided itself into 71 sex the
Christians they divided themselves into
1726 and my ummah will divide itself
into 73 sex right now when you when you
read uh I believe it's
he actually outlines all of the the 72
sects of deviance of like and basically
just kofor bro it's not even deviants at
that point like these people are just
off it but when you look at Shia's we
can't call them cafes
we can call them deviant for sure
because it is deviance but we can't make
takfir on Shields but understand it's
still deviants right so you might as
well do a little bit of research hit us
up on Instagram at three Muslims diamos
if you have any questions we'll talk
about so Nishi and all this in depth
maybe we'll even make a video
but it doesn't matter if you follow
Sunni or Shia it really doesn't
um what matters is what you start to
follow once you start doing this
research if you've been she all your
life call us start following and and
looking into it and understand that
Sunni is correct
and anything else is deviant and I hear
a lot of people saying this argument
that I'm not a sectarian I don't like
dividing you know I'm a Muslim
alhamdulillah you're a Muslim you
understand that Sunni just means you've
basically preserved all the teachings of
what it means to be a Muslim so if you
consider yourself a Muslim and you don't
like anything else you're a Sunni by
definition Sony doesn't mean like you've
subscribed to something additional you
know
you see I will actually
say the opposite as you I would say that
what's most important is that you're
Muslim at the end of the day and to say
that oh if there was no sick then it's
all suddenly
it's understandable but
if I say I'm Sunni
I'm just pertaining myself to a sect
because right now it is a set
so I'd rather just say a Muslim I'd
rather just follow
And in regards to Shia
why don't you just look up Ashura the
day of ashuda
see what people do on the day of Ashura
and you tell me if you want to be a Shia
no actually
no
it's better when we're in person
Rami asked one of the Vlogs coming back
shoulder soon
[Applause]
vlogs oh like the in-person blogs showed
us
I already answered that question brother
Aaron writes that the same what was that
the one that asked how do you control
your desires
let me addresses uh so we can wrap up
the Shia thing
Aaron writes any Shia who commits a
major shift is a cafe Point Blank period
whether ignorant or not go look at what
all the major Stars say yeah bro so any
person period regardless of she or
anything that commit sure you're
comfortable of course
however understanding that you when I
say you can't make takfir on shears you
can make takfir on an entire group like
just saying shias in general or cafes
you can't make takfir on shios bro
because you actually don't know if
they're ignorant or not if you have an
uh Shia that is committing sure you can
make tuck feet on him just like if you
have a Sunni that is committing shirk
you can make the queer on him but Shia
as an entire population you cannot make
the fear on them unless you want to be
called
on a whole group of people
stuff from what I from Scholars is that
these people are following
a Sheikh who is giving them this
information
is the one that's responsible is the one
that will be held accountable
and these people they were ignorant they
did not know so will they be judged or
they careful
we'll find out on the day of judgment
Allah
but it's not up to us to make that
judgment
and even then if it was up to us do you
understand do you understand the amount
of knowledge needed in order to actually
make that fear on someone
and it's not something that's light it's
not light work it's not something that
you would want to make like either it's
it's something very very
is grave
like think about it you're calling
someone
a cafe
you're calling them a disbeliever
imagine that person is closer to Allah
than you
so again leave it to Allah Allah is the
best supplantis he's the one that judges
the best
the best thing that we can do is just
advise
see where they're coming from
and if they are ignorant
show them everything so that they are no
longer ignorant
and then it's up to them
India Marina writes the best prayer is
the home seller Prophet I don't know
about that if it is let's say Hadith
then I'm gonna look into that but I
haven't looked into that at all what I
know is for women
not you throw it on the chat you're
throwing in the chat for women it's
better to pray at home but for men it's
better to pray the Masjid from what I
know
just like in the Masjid it's better for
men to be amongst the front
first row is the best for men and then
for women the last row is the best for
Haya bro and again I will say if you
have not prayed every single prayer at
the Masjid
just try it
that's all music just right
this is the same building again
do you keep popping the same question up
or is that
foreign
Grand bison bro
come on man
Stevo writes do you need to be on
I almost got this demonetized
retention
my question to your question
which are you talking about he's talking
about like when you are
I thought you were gonna say bro my
question is one month up do you follow
no no no no I'm serious I don't like
joking around about these things
which one are you talking about you
talking about being married and then
just never releasing whatsoever are you
talking about
actually that's the only one that we
should be talking about is that what
you're referring to
because if it is what you're referring
to
then yeah you still have value if you
release with your wife I mean
there's gonna be times where you release
with your wife do you think
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
didn't release with his wives was he not
the highest value man in this world come
on
and the proof of this is that he had
kids
before anyone said oh how do you know
Stoke for Allah bro
man
y'all make me sick
Taylor I'm a new Muslim
any tips learning the prayers I gotcha
I got you a new Muslim too damn near two
years ago I'm not a member Muslim
anymore bro you used to be two years ago
alhamdulillah the best way to do this in
my opinion
let's go on YouTube find
the normal prayers right so look for
just
fudger
f-a-j-r
fudger prayer
find one that you like
and then from there what you could do is
you just
keep watching it keep listening to it
and
actually I'm kind of over complicated if
you message me on Instagram inshallah I
will
dmu back I don't I always forget the DM
people but I will DM you back and I will
send you the best stuff but it's just
finding the recitation that you like
from the actual prayer watching it over
and over again memorizing it watching
the video of them doing the player to
get the Motions down even following
along for a little bit I mean I think
some Scholars say that that prayer is
not accepted but probably like
come on a lot Knows Best
so you just do this until you learn and
then you don't need to use videos
anymore and you can just pray by
yourself
but DM me DM me on Instagram
I'm Gonna Let the River brother here
answer this question too
Yusuf hello great oh yes how can I
choose good friends when everyone around
me is a non-muslim
focus on Allah and focus on yourself
it's doable but there will be many many
times where you release
it's just being realistic
Aaron Kaplan writes or Copeland writes
agreed but that kind of ruling is
separate from the Dunya ruling on her in
this life someone who commits major
shirk is a mushrik I wasn't judging
their akara ruling
I don't know bro
I'm not sure if I don't have the
knowledge he's not a Sheikh he's also
not a shield
we're gonna give Shia Sheikh as the good
top three tongue twisters of all time if
you can say this three times send us a
video of you saying it being correct
hijab if you're a man or a woman I'm
just playing and maybe we'll consider
you for the position of our shorts
editor inshallah
brother Ibrahim writes a brother once
said the difference between us and the
Sahara
is we left every Sunnah of rasulullah
because it was only Sunnah
where's the sahaba performed every
Sunnah because it was a Sunnah
I like that
brother
you wrote bro you're right correct
argarta writes yo Brothers can you give
a very small brief on the four schools
of thought I haven't decided one yet
find our podcast that we did with
brother Fletcher who is a white American
River to Islam alhamdulillah
I believe he's he's an unbelief but we
made a video going over all four schools
of thoughts the old video I think it's a
year too old but still relevant
inshallah
awareness of day at the accusation of
shared Kentucky is a very serious
accusation yes I don't think that people
should do it lightly especially on
qualified definitely will you know
mentioned that if you those that make
the fear it might come back to you you
know so be very careful about that yeah
I think the biggest problem nowadays is
the internet because the internet has
caused people to think that their
opinion is of importance and that people
actually care what they have to say
that's not to put anyone down but it's
just to say that that in and of itself
has made people think that oh because I
have
one little bit of information then I
know everything and I'm gonna tell this
person I'm gonna be right because I know
this
in reality like what do we actually know
you know like
the more you learn the more you learn
that you actually know nothing
so I remember Rami talking about it so
maybe it was you fired where in the
beginning you're very very confident
oh it's my tattoo showing I shouldn't do
that
in the beginning you're very confident
so your confidence is like way up here
and then the more you learn and the more
you do things your confidence drops down
because you realize damn but I actually
know nothing and then the more you the
more you learn you go up to like a
reasonable base where now you're not
overconfident
I guess you could say humble so yeah
and to the the queries over here here's
a river goddamn have a little bit of
respect he's accepted Islam Allah has
forgiven him he's made sincere Toba it
doesn't matter so he could be showing it
too but he chooses to hide it for higher
similar bless them for that you remind
me of ottman
who when he would travel he would not
shorten or combine prayers I think I
sent you this this week and the reason
behind this is because he didn't want
when he was asked why do you why do you
not combine and shorten prayers when the
messenger of Allah does that like it's
his Sunnah you know right and then it
doesn't make him better than him or
anything like that but the reason he did
not combine with shorten when traveling
is because all the tribes and and places
that he's traveling to he doesn't want
to give them the impression that this is
the dean of Allah that we shorten
prayers and this is quick and he doesn't
want to lessen the dean of Allah he
doesn't want to water down or dilute The
Deen of Allah subhanallah like that's
that's a man bro
[Music]
no one knew that
of course but it still reminded me of
that that even though you're allowed to
do something you choose not to
um also mentioned about uthman that you
know even the angels are shot of him
similar to how um
you know what I mean but Twilight
revery's rights
because he's not here thank you for your
channel it has allowed me to see the
truth and I took my shahada yesterday
you wanna know what's crazy on home bro
weren't we this close to not starting
this channel
yeah because we didn't feel ready
it's different for everyone man
but a good suggestion would be to look
at your time outside of Salah
are you focused during this time
or are you mindless and just doing
things like all over the place
because if you are not focused in your
time outside of Salah
then what makes you think that during
your time in Salah you're going to be
focused
do you have to choose a school of
thought and what I'm gonna be honest
with you bro I'm a Layman so all I can
tell you is
most people most lay men are not going
to have a school of thought and I forgot
if this was a Hadith or not but it was
either Hadith or a very notable scholar
said that the mudhub of you is your like
the one you look for for knowledge
obviously this is with the exception of
these proper or sorry improper Scholars
that are going to say LG TV is
permissible and You Know Reba is
permissible and all this type of
nonsense but a proper scholar just
follow him and when you are on your
journey inshallah you can follow the
film of a specific mother
sister Amino rights I'm new in Channel
you brother are from West born there and
grew up there
no
I'm not born here I was born in
Bangladesh
and I came to Canada
on home where were we born
I was born in Puerto Rico
when did you come to America I was four
hey I came on those four as well
Rami was born in Canada
lexley writes I have a very heavy
question not sure if I should ask you if
it's appropriate then ask it this is
your time hey man
if you're gonna ask it
better ask it soon because
I know why I think I don't know about
fire but I have to get going
yeah and just ask with your chest bro
if Christians like David wood who lie
about their religion
and who know Islam is the truth then why
don't they accept Islam
perfect
there's a difference between knowing the
truth and submitting to the truth
because Islam at the end of the day is
submission there's many atheists such as
let's say Dr Lawrence Krauss who has
debated homes Resorts as male you know
bless him immensely not Lawrence Krauss
and
it just goes to show how much he
actually probably knows about Islam
David would a post like these people
know a lot about Islam
and many ex-muslims also know a lot
about Islam but the thing is they don't
submit to the truth
so for example when you look at Iblis
right iblies
believes in Allah and believes in not an
atheist right even at least himself
shaytan is not an atheist
but at least despite knowing Allah being
up there with the angels with Allah
seeing the first man being created
he's as bro compared to us human beings
he's seen it all bro
but the thing is even though he believes
in Allah he disobeyed Allah right so I
believe is not in disbelieving in Allah
like an atheist
s and disobeying Allah not submitting it
not submitting to
Allah's Commandments and the dean of
Islam so understand when it comes to
this whole thing about David Ward and
other people that know about Islam it's
simply not enough because knowing is one
thing right accepting it surrendering it
to a submitting to it believing in it
that's a whole different thing that's
What Makes You Muslim a Muslim is one
who submits to the will of God not just
one that knows the will of God
what was the question
the question was if there are people
like David wood for example that you
know spread lies about Islam and other
religions but they also know almost
everything there is compared to like a
Layman that doesn't know anything then
why don't they accept Islam
I mean Allah says in the Quran that
there are some people it's as if
they have a veil covering them they
can't see they can't hear
they can't reason
so it is as if they are different blind
and you also have to look at the example
of the prophet's uncle
there was a Surah revealed that he was
going to go into the Hellfire and all
this stuff
and all they had to do to disprove Islam
was just believe that
I would love all I had to do was believe
and become Muslim and he would have
disproved Islam
so again there's just some people out
there that are like this
the sad thing
the sad thing is when these people are
the ones close to you that's the real
sad thing
and with that
I gotta go pretty much
one more question bro they need you out
here chief
it's Fusion Plex uh how do I stop
listening to music the beats are so
addicting and helps me focus on regular
basis
many things well it could be gym it
could be anything right it's a very
common thing
if I try to quit I always end up coming
back
what would you say oh no
going
and just try quitting for
we'll see a week weeks to anyone can do
a week so do a week no music and instead
of the music just replace it with the
Quran
and yeah just see for yourself
I'll be
assalamu alaikum
I mean likewise
thank you
all right boys I'm probably gonna do
this for a few more minutes and then I'm
gonna head out inshallah I have to pray
Margaret as well
maybe you ever take five to ten more
minutes inshallah
any questions that I will be capable of
answering inshallah we'll do it all
right so
same question from the sister again
define homo is the action or just the
tendency and how much tendency is
another subjective beautiful
so one thing I must clarify here all
right before I even go in is any
mistakes this is going to be on me all
right
any good is obviously from Allah but
anything I say is going to be out of my
ignorance
but it's still in Our obligation to give
the hour and help others when we can
so I don't want you guys to start asking
me photos or anything like that like we
commonly get on this on this channel for
some reason
so LG TV Electronics movement all right
we don't support this we all know
Muslims stand against it however
there's many Muslims
and those that are interested in Islam
that might have this tendency okay let's
talk about this
it's the act in and of itself that is
what is the act the ACT is going through
the back door
this is from Muslims this is for
Christians this is for anyone right but
this is not just man and man this is man
and woman as well all right there's many
reasons why this is Haram
and there's many reasons even outside of
Islam that this is not okay this is not
acceptable bro if you just do a little
bit of research and thinking and
contemplating on it all right it wasn't
designed for this
now when you look at this the action
itself is otaram however this doesn't
mean we should promote this culture and
just tell them to not commit the ACT do
you get what I mean so one thing very
clearly we must understand is this
tendency that we are born with right I
want to be very clear on this
through medical literature and research
that I've done
this is not something that is simply a
choice I want to make this very clear
there are quite literally biological
predispositions that people have when
they're born and they come out of the
womb and this will affect them with homo
proclivities or Tendencies does that
make sense so it doesn't necessarily
mean cool
unborn whatever straight super straight
you know man is a man woman is a woman
there's no gender it's only sex
and anyone that does it it's by choice
so just stop doing it no it's not that
easy right it's been proven that there
is a genetic or biological component to
it
now there's many hypotheses in the
scientific Community why this has come
up for example
the Androgen levels or basically the the
sex hormone levels in you know the
placenta the uterus basically where the
developing fetus is growing in the womb
this area is basically very influencing
into the baby's gender or sex
characteristics once they're born
so I'll try to pin it in the description
if I can if not just DM me I'll try to
send you the studies but
those that are born with a turbulent
amount of androgens not a stable amount
in their mother's womb are going to be
born with these proclivities does that
make sense so simply saying that
you should just shut this off it's not
okay so understand that whether it's an
environmental thing or you're born with
it
you can have proclivities and these
proclivities or Tendencies like the
sister sing
can generally be out of your control
you cannot be punished for anything that
is out of your control
this is not to make you a victim and say
okay cool nothing's in my control no
there is a lot in your control but if
this genuinely is not in your control he
will not be punished for it
if you get graped by someone in your
family or some other someone right then
of course you're not punished for you're
the victim you're generally like you
should try to not be grape to begin with
but if you're literally a victim then
how could you be blamed for that
and when it comes to these Tendencies if
you have these Tendencies You are not
going to be punished for simply having
these Tendencies alone
however it's incumbent upon you it's
absolutely moral upon you it's virtuous
upon you as a Muslim
and I believe even just as a human being
in general that you should do your best
to try to fix yourself
now Society will push acceptance you
know
gender acceptance fat acceptance body
whatever acceptance body positivity we
don't do this over here
a man and a man sorry a man is a man and
a woman is a woman
if you have these proclivities it's an
internal battle it's your test from
Allah
don't blame anyone with this don't be a
victim don't accept it control it I have
known many men that are reverts that you
know once they accepted Islam they
stopped committing this act
because they were gay
and maybe the homosexual proclivities
went away
maybe they got a little bit controlled
maybe they never left doesn't matter
did you do it or did you not
any time you think of doing something
that is a sin
anytime you think of doing something
that is Haram
and you end up doing it you get one sin
if you don't do it you don't get the sin
but you actually get rewarded does that
make sense so think of it like this
you're tempted all the time to commit
this sin but then you actually don't act
on it then on the law you're just
getting rewarded left right and Center
compared to someone else that doesn't
have the proclivity or tendency
then you ask how much tendency is not
subjective listen tendency is tendency
if you have even an ounce of tenancy try
to control it if you buy either sexual
or by curious or just straight out gay
or less it is what it is if you have
this tendency fine if it's out of your
control fine I'm not saying fine as and
I support it I don't support it but fine
isn't call us it's not in your control
but what is in your control is what you
do with it try to curb it try to get
therapy try to get cognitive behavioral
therapy sometimes okay if nothing else
can be done uh consult your share
consult the medical professional
and these things are tests from Allah
for you because Allah has decreed and
permitted this to be a test for you
don't feel the touch no so I'm going to
say
brother Arun asked one is the Andrew Tay
podcast planned insha Allah inshallah
this Andrew Tay podcast is going to be
coming up
in the near future
may go for it
music up to this or it does but
it doesn't make it okay
brother Suleiman writes the ACT is
called this yup and people who do it are
supposed to be called this yup they can
be straight or yeah 100 percent
knowing it is immoral will stop these
Tendencies especially if you prevent
these urges by getting married 100
percent
this is folks
it is again a question of objectivity
and solemnly judged by Allah
kind of
but usually we all know deep down what
is and what isn't
do you guys listen to engineer Ali no I
don't
who is he
I have a question is drawing people and
animals Haram so the scholars have
mentioned not to draw and like imitate
creation
um so far as you don't replicate like
facial features and eyes and stuff like
that but consult The Scholar inshallah
are there any Urdu speaking Scholars you
follow no because I don't speak Urdu
will there be a podcast with Iman godzi
soon inshallah
you know word bro stop asking fair
questions
why is typing inshallah I don't know why
typing inshallah but it should be insha
Allah do you get what I mean it's not
inshallah it's insha Allah
he's working in the field of AI Haram I
can't give photos guys will not qualify
for that
hasanabi supporting lgbtq is shown how
brainwashed he is subhanallah
oh look at him
I mean
how do you avoid degeneracy if you're
moving into college beautiful
if you're moving into college you cannot
avoid degeneracy as in if you're living
on res
kind of like saying how do I walk into
the fire and not get burned
it's an oxymoron what you can do though
to be smart and preemptive is to try
your best to not move to college like
move to Res like residents and dorms and
dormitory stuff like that get like an
off-campus housing even if you have to
walk to stay out of that fascia stay out
of that filth bro trust me when I tell
you this I cannot be more serious when I
say that however if you're already there
do your best to
one be married if you can have the
ability to get married definitely get
married don't go in there uh you know
just like everyone else
I know a lot of parents are going to say
oh finished school then get married
listen kids are going to be doing it
regardless it's either or it's Halal you
choose parents
insha Allah yes that's it
no no I'm not qualified to give photo on
this
stream of done he still feels you set
him up last time inshallah so he joined
our stream a few days or weeks ago I
remember this it was one night and he
basically said that
uh he will get somebody like a Christian
Orthodox scholar someone like that and
he will join us inshallah for round two
so looking forward to that whenever it
happens inshallah
all right a few more questions and then
I'm gonna go pray
do people get crazy in the dorms what if
he what if it's like living with another
Muslim
listen bro in the west stay away from
that
is leaving the USA the best thing for
the future to preserve the classic Stone
culture if you are able to practice your
religion right if you were able to
practice your religion then
alhamdulillah you're that's that's cool
if you're unable to practice your
religion and you're unable to leave
meaning like you're literally you cannot
leave it's impossible you're not
punished for that but you should try to
leave
if you are unable to practice your
religion and you are also able to leave
then leave because you're literally
being stopped from practicing your
religion which is not good and you're
able to leave meaning you have the
choice of going somewhere where you can
practice your religion then go it's
incumbent upon you do so
welcome Salon bro shall I see you
tomorrow
what happened to the stuff is called
live stream that should have dropped a
while ago
he flaked
saying it as it is he never showed
and I'm gonna give him the benefit of
the doubt bro because I always give
everyone the benefit of the doll ones
are you going to do in-person podcasts
in the UK yes inshallah so we have a
whole guest list
Etc
thoughts on sheikhs in Bangladesh
nothing no thoughts
do I play video games I used to when I
was a kid
apartments are expensive they'll grab me
enough financial aid although I mean
I mean
maybe consider getting like a you know a
part-time job or something like that bro
because Dean is priceless trust me I
want to tell you that
uh boys three more questions
it's gonna be mocked up soon
well it already is
so I gotta pray
hope I'm not gonna answer this
Gideon stream coming soon inshallah
girian in person coming soon you already
know
stay tuned for that
okay two more questions
I mean bro
okay that's drum asks thoughts on how to
start gym at 17. I'm gonna say this
if you
have started puberty
the developmental process of puberty
you've had your growth spur you're
satisfied with your height with your
growth right go to the gym just ease
into it start lifting weights watch some
videos on YouTube plenty of resources
head over to firefit.com you already
know maybe it's this way I don't know it
might be inverted because I got you I
will help you that's literally what I do
however understand that
if you're not grown if you still have
height to grow up to
then I personally recommend just give it
another year or two to at least 20 to
grow as much as you can it's not the
weight training in and of itself that
stunts your growth but it's stuff like
overhead movements squats that will you
know do spinal compression stuff like
that and it can start your growth it
doesn't always but it can
so the best thing is to avoid it until
you are a little bit older or a little
bit more mature development wise and in
the meantime do calisthenics body weight
stuff pull-ups push-ups dips stuff like
that
Zade writes I feel like Gideon is going
to troll you I don't know why he he
reached out to us
wants to get a something and we talked
so I don't know I don't think so he
seems like a genuine guy obviously off
camera on camera people are they always
have a persona
flexway it's wooden pull-ups be good for
that guy I did that's why I said that
all right one last question inshallah
then I am Audi
Miller bless you all immensely for
tuning in and share this video inshallah
to share the value like comment
subscribe let me do the last question
and then I will head out
is it permissible to post video game
content on you know come on bro none of
this
I'm like five eight five nine and my
parents don't want me to do weight slow
yeah same thing bro
my parents didn't let me do that too
before I grew up when I was younger I
still did it I used things in the house
believe it or not I would go to Walmart
and I would literally go to like which
is like a grocery store like a
department store many people don't know
what Walmart is and I would go to the
sports section like where they got the
bikes and stuff and I would literally
grab dumbbells and I would do like
dumbbell curls like bicep curls and
shoulder press and you know back rows
and dumbbell rows stuff like that
literally with that because they didn't
let me get a gym membership
and when I was at home I used things at
home so just get creative with them
inshallah
all right may Allah bless you all smash
that like button right now thank you for
tuning in stay tuned for Sunday
inshallah expect all 100 of you or so
there are live viewers right now
currently all about it to make it for
Dylan Madden this Sunday at 1pm a very
close friend of Andrew Tate and
sartorial shooter inshallah
with this being said
may I bless you
I love you all for the sake of Allah